i would like to pass on the stage to dr
raghavendra to take the session ahead
over to you dr ragaveenswood
thank you very much
okay let's uh let's move on ahead and uh
after after a wonderful uh
um
talk on single cell rna sequence
analysis by
by professor sanjeev kumar and i feel a
little bit intimidated to talk about the
same uh topic in the context of talbot
bioinfo platform and how this analysis
analysis can be carried out and and
how you can perform such an analysis
using the platforms uh inbuilt tools let
me quickly share my screen and let's go
over the
uh
topics so uh
since professor sujeeb kumar covered
most of these uh
in in an excellent detail and
and with lot of information
i'm going to and also we are a little
bit short on time so i'm going to
quickly break
glance through or breeze through
some of the um
concepts that he has already explained
in great detail so uh
welcome to welcome to you all one more
time let me share and yeah
yeah so while you you you had already
obtained a lot of inter introduction and
information and explanation regarding
single cell our basic uh data single
server basic
process so let me let us go through all
of these this will be a very good um
opportunity for you also to
summarize what you have grasped so far
in the last
one one hour or one and a half hours so
uh
while it might seem that single cell
rna-seq is is just a natural step
forward from bulk rna seq methods but
the complexity and the heterogeneity of
the single cell data as you had already
uh gotten some information or gotten
some introduction to as well as a
significant reduction in the data
quality that that can be recorded
due to much less rna material for
example is is too high so as as a result
much more emphasis is placed on
normalization and advanced statistical
methods involving machine learning
methods and other
dimensionality reduction methods so
let's uh
let's first understand why we need uh or
how um
this single cell transcriptomics is is
going to be employed so a single cell
transcriptomics represents the profiling
of all the messenger rnas present in one
cell or present in a single cell so the
most widely used technologies that is
used to perform such profiling are quite
different as you had a lot of
introduction to how and
different and variety of different ways
how these could be performed so they are
widely different than what it is usually
done for bulk rna-seq profiling methods
so unlike the bulk rna-seq profiling
methods where the sequencing libraries
are generated from thousands of cells
and an average expression uh analysis or
expression data is what is generated
by measuring these
these bulk rna-seq the single-cell
rna-seq technologies um
isolate single cells by various methods
and then generate cell specific
sequencing libraries by marking the rna
content from a cell with a cell specific
molecular barcode so such such a
technology enables the measurement of uh
transcriptomic information for a range
of thousands or even up to millions of
single cells in right conditions in
correct conditions so uh
let's go over some of the major
differences between these two
technologies and that includes obviously
the distribution of expression levels
measured as an average for bulk bulk
rnaseq while it is measured at the
individual level for the single rna
sequence due to this
scr and ac are more seated to study cell
heterogeneity
cell type identification and the
differentiation of cells over time etc
etc so uh
yeah so um
single cell uh technology has been
around only since 2009 so uh it in the
context of uh genomics or in the context
of uh um human genome project which
originated in 90s this is a very recent
technology so relevant publications and
protocols that is
yeah that are
published demonstrate how this
technology has evolved and how this
technology still continues to diversify
because for for fairly recent technology
this has a really variety of ways how
this can how this uh how this profiling
can be achieved and how this analysis
can be performed and so separating
tissues into cells as a biotechnological
or biotech technological or micro
biological uh protocols has been around
for a long long time so for example it's
been used for cell sorting and other
techniques that have been around for a
long time but the but the
but the differences and the advancement
comes in how this single cell technology
adopts this uh these protocols to
understand the state of the cell at
expression level in a in a great detail
that has not been explored before so it
allows
it allows to study new biological
questions in which stealth cell specific
changes in transcriptome are important
for example uh
cell type identification heterogeneity
of cell responses stochasticity of
a randomness of the gene expression or
pattern within the gene expression based
on the cell type and the inference of
regulatory networks uh gene regulatory
networks across the cells across the
time points so
these are very important applications of
single cell rna-seq
methods and yeah there are the key steps
that uh
key steps involving uh single cell rnac
data analysis is first you have to
extract the cells from the tissues and
isolate the cells one by one so this is
an extensive step and that that can be
executed by a variety of different
technologies and professor sanjeev kumar
has ex
explained in detail and we will also go
over this in a very uh brief manner so
some steps follow bulk sick rna
technology
like library preparation and
amplification these are common for both
but but the
uh but uh
but the way in which the single cells
are isolating the single cells
is performed is completely different
from how
bulk uh rna-seq is handled uh when using
when when the samples are extracted and
rna is
profiled so
so we have to then perform sequencing uh
using ht
high throughput or nga sequencing
methods and then we have to generate a
structured data from these unstructured
first key files and the structured data
in this case will be a count matrix and
which will be employed
for downstream analysis and various
downstream analysis as
as you already have a lot of
introduction too so
so yeah so a single cell rna-seq
analysis includes several steps of
quality control and normalization due to
the small amount of material per cell
and the sensitivity of the sequencing
and it is best uh to identify unreliable
data sets and it is best to exclude this
from the analysis of the rest uh
analysis uh
from the downstream analysis and just
use the rest of the data
that can be uh normalized and that has
to be normalized to be uh to be able to
compare uh and um
and uh yeah perform downstream analysis
um
so broadly speaking
yeah broadly uh broadly speaking the
analysis can be separated into three
different parts so first part deals with
the raw reads by checking the quality
and aligning it to the reference genome
and then the second part deals with the
cell specific data by quality
controlling the cell specific data and
normalizing and eliminating the
artifacts and then by analyzing the
resulting data sets for differences and
differential expression patterns using
clustering techniques and network
analysis which is best suited for time
course data so uh this is this is just a
very brief summary and overview so this
is going to be a little bit repetitive
so let me breathe through it a big part
of single cell rna
sequencing uh profiling is is in the
preparation of data so how can you
separate cells for sequencing that is
that is the
bottleneck in which uh
based on which the single cell rna
sequencing technology is um
has been developed so the methods that
can be uh the methods can be categorized
into different ways but the two most
important aspects are the approaches
that these methods rely on for capture
of the cells and quantification of the
cells so one is a micro well method
which
which performs or which utilizes a
series of micro scale wells that will be
or that are used to capture the cellular
materials the cells are isolated using
pipettes or laser captures and they are
placed separately in these microfluidic
wells so a major advantage of such
well-based methods uh are
is that um
they can be combined with fluorescent
activated cell sorting techniques and it
is possible to select cells based on the
surface markers and based on the
differences that one can observe in the
surface and this strategy is very useful
for situations where one wants to
isolate specific subset of cells
for sequencing so one of the main
drawbacks in such a methods or such
well-based method is that there are
often low throughput methods and the
material gets wasted a lot by separation
and the amount of work required to get a
personal um
output may be uh yeah may not be
considerable so uh the another uh
technique based on which this uh
this capturing of cells is performed is
microfluidic platforms so uh they
provide a more
integrated system for capturing cells
and for carrying out reactions that are
necessary for library preparations these
platforms provide a higher throughput
than microwave-based platforms typically
around only 10 percentage of the cells
that are captured in microfluidic
platforms and thus they are not
appropriate uh if one is dealing with
rare cell types and very small amounts
of input so these these these are the
considerations that you have to take or
you have to make
when when you have to choose which
method or which platform that you want
to employ so moreover the chip that is
used for microfluidic platforms is
relatively expensive but since the
reactions can be carried out in smaller
volume and money can be saved on
reagents and other
chemicals so
the third one will be the idea behind a
droplet-based method is to
encapsulate us as
as explained multiple times by professor
sanjeev kumar also in the answers also
in the questions answer to the questions
so is to encapsulate each and individual
cells inside a nanoliter droplet
together with a bead so the bead as you
have been explained is loaded with
enzymes that is required to construct
the library and in particular each bead
contains a unique bar code which is
attached to all the reeds originating
from that particular cell or from the
specific cell thus all the droplets can
be pulled and sequenced together and the
reads can subsequently be assigned to
the cells of uh cells of origin based on
the unique bar codes that is cell
dependent uh
or cell specific so the droplets
performed typically platforms typically
have highest throughput
of all the methods that we have
discussed so far and the library
preparation costs are on the order of
what less than one dollar per cell um
but while the preparation costs are very
low the sequencing costs often will
become the limiting factor and thus a
typical experiment uh
is where is what uh typical experiment
should involve uh a lot of coverage uh
and hence uh yeah and hence uh the cost
will shoot up in that uh
in that dimension so uh
let's look at some of the quantification
approaches for a single cell rna
techniques or yeah
so for quantification approaches there
are two main approaches the full length
and tag based and the former
full-length
approaches tries to achieve the uniform
read coverage of each transcript because
the full length is being uh used for the
used for the uh
quantification but in contrast uh
tag-based uh protocols or tag-based
approaches capture only either the five
prime end or other three prime end to
which the tags are attached so the
choice of this method is very important
and has serious implications in in the
downstream analysis and what types of
analysis that the data can be used for
so because in theory full-length
protocols should provide an even
coverage of transcripts but we will see
or we shall see or we often see that
there are often biases in this uh
coverage so the main advantages the main
advantages of tag-based protocol
in contrast is that they can be combined
with
umis or unique molecular identifiers
which can help
help us improve the level of
quantification that one can achieve from
these analysis on the other hand
using these barcodes are using these
tag-based protocols to quantify the
genes
we are restricted to one end of the
transcript and this may reduce the map
ability and it may also make it harder
to distinguish different isoforms so
yeah uh
so the microfluidics based single cell
rnac can be covered in some of the major
steps that we are going to discuss in in
a very uh very brief
few slides two or three slides so first
you have to uh the preparation in the
preparation stage the cells are
suspended to form complex tissue uh from
a cells are suspended from
from a complex tissue to isolate these
cells into
different cell types
based on different isolation methods so
the synthesis of primers using bar coded
primer beads that attaches
to barcodes of these different cell
types so that will actually
segregate us specify
which cell type or which
read that originate from which cell type
and then
then the microfluidic device
forms a major component
which captures the cells in oil droplets
with which contains barcoded beads and
also which contains the necessary
components and enzymes for
for
sequencing uh protocols or sequencing
methods so next
so
yeah the next the barcoding
of these molecules inside each cell each
cell has to be packed by unique barcode
to identify uh to identify those
specific cells during analysis methods
because these bar codes will become the
um
become the sequences or will become the
tag which will quantify those mrnas and
which will segregate those mrna to those
specific cells so this has to be
performed and
yeah the barcodes are added to the oil
droplets uh together with the cells and
buffered which breaks the cell membranes
and the mrnas are then attached to the
poly t tails of the barcodes
and then these barcodes are then
attached to these
mrnas and then
and then they are proceeded for
sequencing so these barcodes actually
contain two two parts technically they
contain two parts one of the parts or
one component is the cell barcode
which is yeah
which is
similar to all the molecules in one oil
droplet so in in one droplet we have one
cell and all the mrna molecules from
that one cell will have one unique
uh
cell barcode so that identifies uh the
relationship or that identifies the
source of that mrna molecules from that
particular cell and then you we have
unique molecular identifier which will
allow each mrna prior to pcr application
to have a separate barcode so these two
components will help in i will help in
first distinguishing mrna molecules for
uh for different or for specific cell
types and also will help in identifying
uh
biases that are introduced during pcr
amplification methods so
yeah and then
we will have to yeah and then the cells
are lysist lies and cell isis is
performed and rna hybridization is
performed so immediately after the
droplet is formed the each cell is lysed
within the droplet and its mrnas are
released then the mrnas are hybridized
to the primers on its uh micro particle
surface surface and then forms uh the
stamp that professor talked about single
cell transcriptomes attached to these
micro particles and after the mrnas are
attached the droplets are broken by
adding necessary reagents to destabilize
the oil water interface and the micro
particles are collected and then washed
so the mrnas are then reverse
transcribed into dnas
together in in a reaction and they form
are forming a set of beads called single
cell transcriptomes attached to micro
particles these these are the stamps in
which the
the transcriptomes are attached to the
particles in the center so and then we
have to amplify these stamps and the
barcoded stamps can then be amplified by
pcr methods
for
to necessary level that is required
for the high throughput mrna sequencing
methods so
so for sequencing and
analysis the resulting molecules are
then sequenced using high capacity
parallel sequencing and the reads are
first aligned to reference genome to
identify the gene of origin of the cdna
and then the reads are organized by
their uh bar codes
yeah and they're okay it's a bit bigger
for some reason it's yeah
so this is how
the pipeline can be
initiated in the t bioinfo platform
yes little bit better now so uh so these
molecules uh the resulting molecules are
then sequenced in high capacity parallel
sequencing as you as you know as you had
introduction to and then the reads are
first aligned to reference genome to
identify the gene of origin of the cdnas
and then the reeds are organized by cell
barcodes and the number of mrna
transcripts that
constitute to each gene
for each cell is digitally counted so
this is where the umis and the cell
barcodes come into play and this will
help us in this will help us
avoid double counting of sequence reads
from the same mri and transcripts and
then this will help us build a matrix of
digital gene expression measurements
that can be established for our or that
can be
leveraged for our further analysis so to
build the pipeline of scrna sequences on
uh
on tbio info platform we can select
appropriate algorithms that can be
chosen based on the sequencing data that
we have the steps involved the steps
include pre-processing and then mapping
and assigning reads to transcripts and
identify cells using barcodes
demultiplexing and then
proceed forward to
quantification artifact correction cell
to cell similarity identification
visualization so this this is
comparatively a long uh
a long pipeline
because of the necessary that single
cell rna technology
requires so that we should not we should
eliminate
we should eliminate uh
um
and normalize eliminate uh
outliers and normalize uh the
normalized uh the expression counts or
normalize the data uh to be able to be
uh to be uh to enable us to compare
different cell types so uh
yeah a consolidated pipeline will look
something like similar to this and at
the end of this pipeline you can submit
it and then this is going to give us a
gene count matrix or count matrix
which can be downloaded from the
pipeline outputs
okay
yeah
so when you open this file so
technically when you open this file what
we have is uh
um the columns of the table that we have
here are are the cells that are
represented by the cell barcodes uh in
the
in here
and in the row we have uh genes are
ensemble ids and
in the intersection we have the
expression values of these genes each
are distinctly i mean of the genes for
each distinctly barcoded cell types and
that are given in
raw count values so the goal of the data
that is used for this analysis was to
identify
different classes of cells this this
particular data that we are seeing here
is um is
is used to identify the different
classes of cells in the murine amygdala
uh
tissue and thus
we will use known molecular marker genes
that are necessary to understand which
cell types are present in the table that
we just generated or just the table that
is just generated from the upstream
analysis of
unstructured data to structured data so
we now restrict ourselves or we now
subset or select only those genes that
are known to be markers of different
cell types and we generate a smaller
table from this bigger larger table and
then this table is has to be technically
log normalized and then
subjected to principal component
analysis we can examine how the cells or
how distinct cell types uh are clustered
are separated into
different clusters
based on the marker gene so this this
marker gene is using
this segregation or this separation
based on the marker gene will give us
an overview or exploratory analysis
overview
of how these cells
separate or cluster
in the
in the gene expression
count data distribution that we have
so more sophisticated visualization and
dimensionality reduction techniques like
psne and disney and umap will be able to
visualize and cluster specifically
distinct group of cells based on the
gene expression counts that we have
obtained and that is that forms the
exploratory analysis and that that forms
a downstream analysis um after
performing this exploratory analysis we
have to move towards downstream analysis
which will be more sophisticated or
which
will involve sophisticated algorithms so
once we have the count metrics and once
we have explored our data for for the
possibility and for the
presence of patterns within the data
then we can
go and um
and employ a number of computational
methods that will help us to perform
downstream analysis and one such method
is one such package is curate and
yeah professor also uh talked about see
red so i will tell you how this can be
how this pipeline can be enabled or how
this pipeline now how different
components of this pipeline come
together in the in the single cell data
analysis that can be employed in t
bioinfo platform so the first first few
steps is to
create or to in
to generate a series objects for each
sample and then to check quality control
and and select only good quality cells
for each sample and then we have to
normalize the data for each sample and
then highly identified highly variable
features for each sample or highly
variable genes for each sample which
will
which will specifically define
the cell types so and then we have to
perform some integration and we have to
scale the data so that all the
expression counts or all the data from
multiple different uh sequencing
cell types are in the similar scale and
then we we then
perform linear dimensionality reduction
methods like pca and then we remove uh
uh
yeah and then we remove
yeah uh
not not to remove and
we perform this dimensionality direction
piece here to reduce the number of
dimensions that we are going to analyze
with and then we go to
remove batch effects using harmony and
then we go uh
then we continue to cluster
key components or cluster cell types
find by finding neighbors and by finding
clusters and patterns within the
expression patterns and then we also
perform nonlinear dimensional
interaction using new map and disney and
that will help us
that will help us and identify cluster
um
in the low dimensional space or
cluster in the reduced dimensional space
and these clusters can then be assigned
to different cell types based on the
marker genes that we have and then once
uh identified once these clusters are
identified and once these uh different
clusters are distinct clusters are uh
identified from the umap and disney and
other clustering methods then we can
finally
establish contrast for which
differentially expressed genes can be
identified and differentially extra
genes can be
quantified and we can
analyze and interpret those genes that
are
that forms or that form significantly
upregulated or down regulated on
for different uh
distinct cell types and uh yeah
interpolate uh extrapolate that analysis
to
relevant biological interpretations so
to select only good quality cells one
has to keep some of the considerations
in mind and one one basic consideration
or one important consideration would be
the number of unique genes detected in
each cells and low quality cells are
empty droplets will often have very few
genes so uh
so filtering it out based on the number
of
unique genes will become an important
filter steps and
yeah
while on the other hand
cell doublets or cell multiples may
exist exhibit or may uh may display
an abnormally high gene count so you
have to make sure that you have to
filter out both
low quality cells and
cells which have more than or droplets
which have more than one cells or fused
cells in them
so that they will not
interfere in our quantification of this
single cell rna
analysis so the percentage of reads that
that map to the mitochondrial genome
will also become very uh yeah will also
be uh will also have to be removed and
uh
this this will this will this is done
due to the fact that low quality cells
or dead cells often exhibit extensive
mitochondrial contamination so hence
to be to be careful and to
eliminate those cells we have to
completely remove mitochondrial
contamination for example in this case
the percentage of mitochondrial
contamination in these two cells or in
these two
samples
is almost nil so we don't have to employ
that filter in this case
and and the next will become uh
standardization or next uh
the standardized variance plot of uh um
can you help me yes thank you very much
yes
yeah
so a standardized variance plot will
help us identify a subset of genes
that are
that are found or that can be identified
to be uh um expressed in a very high
level from cell to cell uh uh in a cell
to cell variants um
yes in social uh
differences are between different cells
and using this plot we can identify
those genes and um
and and
employ those genes and analyze and
interpret and use those genes to
differentiate between the cell types and
differentiate between
how
the distinct gene expression patterns
differ from differ
among those cell types and how it can be
used to
characterize and how it can be used to
explain the differences that we observe
in the cell type so identifying these
highly variable genes will become
extremely important uh
in our
downstream analysis and and next comes
uh
after this we
comes
one has to perform a non-linear
dimensionality reduction techniques or
methods like umap or tsp that can be
performed based on the top principle
components that is
that one calculates and we can use this
to visualize patterns in the data we can
use this to cluster uh cells that have a
similar expression patterns and we can
use this to identify differences between
these clusters
based on their segregation and
separation patterns so from these
identification of multiple different
clusters to annotation of clusters can
be carried out based on the cluster
specific marker genes
me
yeah thank you sonalika so uh annotation
of clusters then can be carried out
based on the cluster specific top marker
genes which is used to identify cell
types in each cluster so this annotation
then after identifying or after
annotating these cluster types can be
transformed or transferred into the
clusters that we have identified or we
have generated in the
in the umap or tsne non-detection
dimensionality reduction methods and
they can be visualized to give us a
segregation based on the gene expression
distribution so
these expression patterns that govern
the distinct cell types can be can also
be visualized as a
as a method or as a
dot plot which represents simply a
percentage of expression levels based on
multiple samples of multiple cell types
are based on multiple uh
genes that we have and and these give
give us the uh
this gives us the
genes that that are
that are
regulated upregulated or downregulated
between uh different cell types so now
that we have identified distinct cell
types and
we have identified and
annotated existing cell types and we can
go on to perform a differentially
differential gene expression analysis
between the between multiple different
cell types and you based on these
comparisons one can
perform a detailed uh what can
one can extrapolate that to understand
the differences between the cell types
and one can perform a detailed
comparative and analysis uh on the cell
types uh um
or uh
or cells from different time points so
it depends on the sample that we have
so to
so far to summarize the analysis or the
logic of the analysis that one can
one one has to employ for single cell
rna analysis uh techniques let's take a
look at these simplified steps so we map
the reads and we get the bam or sam file
just like a regular rna-seq pipeline and
then we map the r codes and we produce a
table of molecular counts which is
similar to table of expression and then
we check for artifacts and then we
update the table of expression and then
we normalize the data and then a
similarity matrix
it has to be prepared and is calculated
based on the molecular counts and
based on the cell to cell distances
based on these molecular accounts of
this and that will that cell to cell
distances will form the basis in which
we can cluster or we can perform
trajectory analysis of our data so yeah
depending upon
depending upon whether
we want to find different groups of
cells
based on
whether we want to find different groups
of cells
that is present in the sample based on
the transcription profiles or whether we
want to analyze the cell development uh
stages of cell development
steps over time so clustering helps us
clustering like these methods help us
identify cells that are similar that
have similar expression patterns and
assigning them and assigns them to
distinct group as we have already seen
this is often performed using
a dimensionality reduction technique
like pca or disney
and trajectory analysis
is the one which is going to help us
identify which is going to help us
compare uh cell differentiation or
cells that have different expression
level based on the differentiation time
and and based on the uh
based on uh
when or based on the
trajectory of these differentiation
times so
all these information analysis methods
i'll go back
all these information analysis methods
and the logic behind these methods and
the choice of the algorithms that you
have to employ and how to do on how to
run these algorithms and how to perform
the downstream analysis are discussed in
much much greater detail and in very
yeah
and in very
[Music]
logic based and modular
way in the omics logic platform and i
encourage you all to go through and
go through the lessons and check that
out and
yeah experience
experience the single cell analysis
pipeline so that
you can develop uh
develop an appreciation for uh for the
uh promise and for the potential that
singles rna-seq analysis has in
understanding and in answering some key
biological questions that
bulk cell rna analysis cannot be
employed for so i will take questions